nos dicen que observa el plano
coordinado de arriba yo lo puse aquí a
un lado identifica un sistema de dos
rectas que tiene una única solución
entonces identifica un sistema de dos
rectas que no tiene solución que no
tiene solución hagamos la primera parte
un sistema con una única solución única
solución nos piden identificar un
sistema pero podemos ver que aquí va a
haber dos sistemas que tienen una única
solución cuando hablamos de una única
solución estamos hablando de un único
punto de coordenadas x que satisface
ambas ecuaciones del sistema así es que
cuando vemos a los puntos de
intersección este punto de aquí
satisface la ecuación de esta recta roja
la ecuación de igual a 0.1 x más 1 y
también se encuentra sobre esta línea
azul se encuentra sobre la gráfica que
representa la ecuación igual a 4 x + 10
así es que este punto de aquí representa
la solución al sistema formado por estas
dos ecuaciones esto también lo podemos
ver como el punto x
que cumple con ambas restricciones así
es que un sistema que tiene una única
solución es el que consta de la ecuación
igual a 0.1 x + 1 y la ecuación
representada por esta recta azul que es
la ecuación de igual a 4x más 10 ahora
solo nos piden identificar un sistema de
dos rectas que tenga una única solución
lo cual ya hemos hecho pero para que lo
veas también hay otro sistema que cumple
con eso así es que este es un sistema y
otro sistema es el formado por esta
recta verde y esta recta roja este punto
de intersección que tenemos aquí
de nueva cuenta representa el valor de
xy que cumple tanto con la ecuación de
esta recta roja que es igual a punto 1 x
1 igual a 0.1 x + 1 al mismo tiempo que
cumple con la ecuación representada por
esta recta verde que es la ecuación de
igual a 4x menos 6 así es que si ves
este sistema tiene una única solución
pues las rectas que lo representan
tienen un único punto de intersección al
igual que este sistema
que tiene un único punto de intersección
ahora la segunda parte del problema nos
pide identificar un sistema de dos
rectas que no tiene solución así es que
un sistema que no tenga solución sin
solución
ahora para que un sistema no tenga
solución significa que las dos
restricciones no se traslapan que no
existen valores que cumplan con las dos
ecuaciones no hay una pareja de valores
xy que sea común a las dos rectas y eso
es lo que pasa con estas dos rectas
paralelas la recta azul y la recta verde
dado que nunca se intersectan no existe
un punto coordenada que cumpla con las
dos ecuaciones no existe una pareja xy
que cumpla con ambas así es que la
respuesta a la segunda parte es el
sistema conformado por la recta ye igual
a 4 x + 10 y la recta
ye igual a 4 x menos 6 y observa las dos
rectas tienen exactamente exactamente la
misma pendiente son rectas distintas
pues tienen ordenada al origen diferente
así es que nunca se intersectan y por
eso el sistema no tiene solución